I thought we were gonna go heard your  mother trampolining  superheroes are illegal you want to  fight bad guys defines Who I am  we're not saying you have what someone  on TV said I was approached by this  tycoon most talked-about hero stuff help  me bring supers back into the sunlight  we need Elastigirl  [Music]  two kids no problem  not the way you're supposed to do it dad  they want us to do it I don't know that  way why would they change math over  Dusseldorf do those are dodging Kyle s  so heavy that rupee clothing I could  have done this if you hadn't taken over  so well I've got to succeed so she can  succeed  can she get it Bob is tricky but I can't  keep giving him cookies done properly  parenting is a heroic act done properly  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  you